so there's this company called Mizzou
soft they sell a subscription service
that essentially lets you cheat at
Rainbow six siege and they advertise
themselves with an ear clean detection
record too bad for them they couldn't
keep themselves undetected because
Ubisoft the makers of Rainbow six siege
are suing their asses let me tell you
the whole story okay so like I said this
company sells cheats and that's nothing
new but what's weird about this service
is they're kind of like the Spotify of
hacks they charge a monthly fee for
their service people pay seventy seven
dollars a month to have access to their
cheats and apparently the software lets
you do two things it lets you see
opponents and non player characters
through map boundaries like walls or
landscape it also apparently multiplies
damage and reduces recoil on your
weapons basically they give you wall
hacks and put the game on easy mode when
you're shooting they kind of make it
sound like it's the best cheating
software in the world like you'll win
more games but nobody will be able to
notice that you're cheap we obviously
see this stuff in gaming all the time
various forms of cheating wall hacks
embodying and team [ __ ] just the other
day we published a video about phase
Jarvis cheating for content and format
but honestly I can never [ __ ]
remember someone making a subscription
service for cheating it's like they
think this is Netflix or something now
naturally as is the case with like every
cheating software of all time Ubisoft
the makers of the game found out about
it and they and the Rainbow six
community were pissed it seemed to be
told like the cheat itself looked really
weird like when he was playing his own
character turned this sort of neon mint
green yeah and it's like what is what is
the purpose of that and this stuff blew
up in the community so hard that Ubisoft
is suing the [ __ ] here's what they
had to say in the lawsuit about the way
that this cheating impacts their game
the defendants conduct has caused and is
continuing to cause massive and
irreparable harm to Ubisoft and its
business interests the u sauce business
depends upon its games being enjoyable
in fair
for all players and Ubisoft spends an
enormous amount of time and money to
ensure that this is the case the
cheating software destroys the integrity
of Rainbow six siege thereby alienating
and frustrating legitimate players so
yeah
cheating sucks they're suing all 12
operators involved with this
organization and asking that the service
be taken offline immediately they're
also seeking damages which could add up
to $25,000 fine for each violation movie
soft sites in the loss and according to
the lawsuit this software has been
downloaded thousands of times by our six
players if you want some perspective on
cheating within the game in July of 2018
Ubisoft suspended more than 1300 players
alone for cheap now the lawsuit suggests
that cheating like this can harm the
integrity of the game but it takes a
little further into just how strange
this company's marketing seems to me let
me read this passage the defendants are
the founders and operators of a business
enterprise formerly known as cheap boost
and now known as mizu soft music soft
ascribes itself as quote a leading cheap
provider and a company that focuses on
creating easy to use an undetected
cheating software a leading cheap
provider are you [ __ ] kidding me they
aren't even trying to hide what they're
doing this gets a little bit more crazy
as despite describing themselves as a
leading cheap provider or whatever that
means they seem to only make cheats for
literally Rainbow six it's like they're
trying to pose as this poured unquote
legitimate cheap business while mostly
just hacking Rainbow six so as you might
imagine creating this service breaks a
lot of rules and laws which is exactly
what the lawsuit says according to the
suit me so soft is violating section one
to zero one of the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act by selling and creating a
product that evades the anti-cheating
measures embedded into the game which of
course is grounds for Ubisoft to sue all
right so if you to know for all that
boring legal stuff let's catch up a
little bit here okay so a company made a
cheat then got sued makes sense right
well I think maybe the craziest thing
about this whole story is how this
company ended up getting caught in the
first place one of the founders
literally went on the BBC and did an
interview about building this program
I really made a cheat a snack man this
is awesome I want to do this more it was
only a hobby the den RV last section in
that I could make a lot of money on it
because it's the only job I have at the
moment oh look at that so already I can
move loaded up and I can see much
further I can now shoot completely in
one spot without any recoil and when I
shoot someone it hurts them a lot more
of this is a completely different game
now yeah the interview was honestly kind
of strange
and oddly glorifies cheated this guy
went on camera with like a hat and a
mask and talked about how much money he
was making and how easy it was to do
this and I'm not the only one that
thought this was crazy
this each community thought this was
[ __ ] too and as soon as they saw the
interview everybody took to Twitter and
an investigation started immediately
it's like these guys chose to go on
camera look like these sneaky cheaters
who were too smart to ever get caught
and then they obviously immediately got
caught and soon so there you have it one
of the craziest and honestly stupidest
stories about cheating I have ever
earned if you want to take anything away
from this video don't [ __ ] cheat but
if you are gonna cheat don't go on TV
and advertise if you had seventy seven
extra dollars a month Matt what would
you buy